Do you want to hear a secret?
Hold on.
Before I quench your curiosity, let me remind
you that some things are better off left not
knowing.
Pry around long enough and you’re sure to
find something you weren’t looking for.
That is to say, not every treasure chest is
filled with gold coins, elegant jewelry, and
expensive relics.
Maybe it’s not even a treasure chest at
all.
Dumpsters do look quite similar, don’t they?
Peek inside and you might find rotting meat,
an army of maggots, and a smell that stings
your nostrils.
So, do you want to hear a secret now?
Pshh.
Of course, you do.
No disclaimer could stand in the way of humanity
and hot gossip.
Look at the world around you.
Everything revolves around information.
The more we know, the more we can say.
And is there anything people want more than
something to say?
Next time you’re at a nice restaurant with
a group of friends or coworkers or family,
look across from you and notice how hard lips
have to refrain from belting out, interjecting,
or adding two cents.
Humans can’t help but throw their words
into the universe, as if they will echo in
importance for eternity.
Some might say that listening is a skill.
However, you can argue that it is simply a
prerequisite to speaking.
It is a deal we make.
A compromise.
If we listen, then we get to speak!
If we hear a secret, we get to share it.
So we spend our lives listening, observing,
and gathering information about the people,
places, and things around us.
Philosophers and scientists like to call it,
“The pursuit of truth.”
But who are we kidding?
It is a chore.
A task completed only for the prize that comes
with it: the chance to speak about what we’ve
seen, heard, and learned.
Most often, this journey of gathering information
isn’t as profound as we pretend it is.
Digging around other people’s business is
no noble task.
But curiosity is like a shiny shovel, and
to let a tool like this rust in the shed would
be a sin.
Wouldn’t it?
So, with that said, let’s stop pretending
we don’t love TMZ.
Let’s indulge in our lust for secrets.
Let’s get digging.
Deep into the mystery of SCP-1903.
Like with understanding any artifact, culture,
or ideology, we have to first look at the
earliest origins of our subject to comprehend
its current state.
This is to say, SCP-1903 wasn’t always SCP-1903.
Once upon a time, she was Jackie.
Jackie Barter.
A woman who dedicated herself to her job,
trying to make a better life for herself.
Jackie Barter valued her work above anything
else.
She did her job and never complained.
She showed up early and always smiled.
Whether she enjoyed it, however, was another
thing.
It’s hard to know anyone’s true feelings
at their workplace.
But we can speculate that her clients enjoyed
it more.
So, what was it that she did exactly for work?
What was her job title when she filed taxes?
What did her day-to-day shift look like?
If only it was that easy.
She handled her responsibilities behind closed
doors, and there was an agreement between
her, her clients, and her boss – Mr. Donnar
– not to speak of what happened behind said
doors.
In a way, these customers were paying for
privacy.
At the same time, and maybe more importantly,
they were paying for Jackie.
Jackie Barter was one of the primary reasons
why Mr. Donnar was a success.
Sure, he had a knack for business.
He knew how to operate in the shadows of anonymity.
He knew how to turn a profit.
But most importantly, he knew what his clients
wanted.
And what they wanted was Jackie.
But what exactly did she do?
What was she offering?
Why did they want her?
The tight-lipped Donnar never made those easy
questions to answer.
However, what we do know is that she was in
the service industry… and she wasn’t bringing
food or drinks to her clients.
Jackie Barter, herself, was enough for them.
She brought her energy, her smile, her personality,
her charm, and her glow.
She dressed in a white dress and wore novelty
bunny ears.
The wardrobe never changed.
It never had to.
While customers came to Donnar’s establishment
to mix things up from their normal lives,
when they were there, they didn’t want change.
They wanted the same thing each time.
They knew what they wanted, and it was Jackie
Barter.
Jackie Barter in a white dress and bunny ears.
What she actually did, however, isn’t as
clear, but if you were to speculate, you’d
likely come to some version of the truth.
What is clear is who she did it for.
A man who we will refer to as A.F was her
top client.
A.F managed the chemical plant a few blocks
from the establishment.
He had a wife, a high-income job, and had
the means to live a good life.
He had things going for him, everything he
could ever want.
But like any man built of vices, he wanted
more.
Mr. Donnar’s establishment was made for
people like AF.
It was a place where people could be influenced
by the devil on their left shoulder and not
be judged for it.
It was a place for depravity detached from
morality.
It was a place where you didn’t have to
shape your behavior to the expectations of
society, family, or friends.
More than that, it was a place where people
themselves didn’t feel guilty for what they
did.
Mr. Donnar created a place where people could
act on their impulses, enjoy themselves, walk
out, go home, and leave their shame at the
door.
AF loved every aspect of it.
And so, he became a local.
He went frequently, and he always requested
Jackie.
Donnar operated his business in a vague, mysterious
building.
The type of place you’d have to Yelp three
times before entering just to make sure you’re
at the right address.
It looked abandoned, and yet, you could feel
the life behind those doors.
It pulled you in.
Inside, there were rooms lined up like a hotel
hallway.
Behind one of those particular doors waited
not just one man, but rather a crew of friends.
AF always brought about three or four people
with him.
Why he brought them isn’t understood.
Did he feel safer in his sins when shared
with others?
Or is it that he was trying to impress them?
Or maybe he was up to no good and wanted to
have the numbers on his side.
What we do know, is that whoever these men
were, AF had an abundance of them.
Each time he visited the establishment, he
brought a different group of people with him.
But the variance ended there.
Because each time, his request was exactly
the same: the “woman dressed in white".
He wanted Jackie, and only Jackie.
She was his preferred handler.
The reasons for this aren’t clear.
It might be as simple as a man having a specific
taste.
They might have gotten along quite well.
Or maybe there’s more to it.
Maybe he was up to something.
Why he chose her, we don’t know.
But we do know he loved his time with Jackie.
Little did he know, his time with her was
running out.
Soon she would be someone, or something, entirely
new.
SCP-1903.
What happened that night behind closed doors,
we aren’t sure.
But don’t let that stop you from speculating.
After AF returned home, his wife went to Donnar’s
establishment looking for information, no
different than you are seeking information
right now, listening closely, waiting for
the next bomb to drop.
Only she wasn’t at her computer.
She was actively fighting for it.
Donnar, being a man dedicated to privacy,
kept his mouth shut and sent her away.
But AF’s wife didn’t give up.
She knew something was off.
And so she tracked Jackie down after hours.
Unlike her confrontational encounter with
Donnar, she was able to ease into a friendly
conversation with Jackie and coax information
out of her, slowly but surely.
Jackie opened up and told her everything.
She told her all about AF’s late nights
spent there at Donnar’s establishment and
about the men he’d bring with him.
More specifically, Jackie explained to her
what happened the night in question.
And whatever it was, it was enough for Jackie
not to come in the next day.
And in the days following, that’s when everything
changed for Jackie.
Over the course of the next few days, she
painfully morphed into what we see her to
be now.
SCP-1903.
It started in her face.
Nothing that would concern anyone at first
glance.
Her cheeks turned slightly pink.
But the symptoms wouldn’t be overlooked
for long.
She developed dark claw-like hands and feet.
The skin on her face turned into what looks
like a paper mâché-styled rabbit mask.
Her bunny ears no longer were just for show,
but rather they are entirely responsible for
her ability to hear.
She began to produce mercury and blood through
the pores of her hands and feet.
No longer was she Jackie Barter.
The Foundation stepped in and took her into
their own custody and deemed her SCP-1903.
This, however, did not come without consequence
for the Foundation.
The discovery of SCP-1903 and the knowledge
obtained and passed along should not have
been celebrated.
But they didn’t know this until the party
had already started.
And when the balloons began to pop, it was
already too late.
Let this be a lesson, be careful of the secrets
you tell.
Unlike most curiosities, this one came at
a cost no contestant on The Price is Right
could ever have guessed.
We are creatures who crave information, and
we will dig around until we get it.
And once retrieved, it is instinct to hold
it up and show the world.
Mostly, this is innocuous.
However, sometimes, when someone spills the
tea… we all get burned.
And that is exactly what happened.
SCP-1903 was discovered by the Foundation
to harbor a slow-acting infohazard.
The effects of this infohazard are triggered
when the subject learns three important details
of Jackie's story.
1) AF’s full name
2) AF’s actions toward Jackie
3) And Jackie’s response to AF’s actions.
Sorry, Lebron, Bosh, and Wade, but no big
three in NBA history has ever been as powerful
as this one.
It is the catalyst for years of damage.
If not guarded properly, it has the force
to dismantle entire dynasties.
As the Foundation spread this information
throughout personal, so spread the infection
across the research team.
Anyone who learned too much of the story was
and will be afflicted.
But what exactly does that look like?
Well, subjects will begin showing symptoms
of mercury poisoning, and large parts of skin
will flake off exclusively around the facial
area two days after exposure to the trigger
information.
After five days, typically when the pigmentation
of the affected area is a pure white in color,
the dermis will begin to form a protective
layer of similar composition to SCP-1903's
mask, with the exclusion of any traces of
mercury.
This layer will continue to form until it
covers the entire facial area and will eventually
appear to resemble a paper mâché animal
mask of a similar fashion to SCP-1903's, which
typically resembles rabbits, cats, wolves,
foxes, and rats.
They will go biologically deaf, and they will
only be able to hear if they continue to wear
these ears.
Over the course of this change, the hands
and feet will undergo a pigmentation shift,
darkening considerably.
Their nails will sharpen, growing into claws
over time, and the subject's hearing will
transfer to the nearest set of novelty ears
which represent the animal that their masks
resemble.
Once subjects have found these ears, they
will show reluctance to take them off.
It is unclear if this is because they have
built a bond with their identity, or if it
is simply the case of them trying to preserve
their hearing.
Furthermore, if a pair of ears become damaged
to the point where repair without spare parts
is impossible, the subject will become permanently
deaf.
And they will be left wishing their deafness
had come sooner, saving them from hearing
Jackie’s secret, saving them from the curse
that comes with it.
Maybe they even wish they mute too.
Because once an affected subject tells a non-affected
subject about the trigger information, the
normal subject will undergo the changes the
affected subject went through up until that
point.
Thus continuing this chain of unfortunate
fate.
Two to three days later, blood will begin
to seep through the pores in the subject's
hands, feet, and gums.
Within a few hours, mercury will begin to
appear in the subject's bloodstream.
This does not physically affect the subject
or other subjects in a similar state.
However, it does severely affect the subject's
mental health.
Many afflicted subjects have been reported
to go to extreme measures to remove the mask
that has overtaken their face.
AF was one of them.
He sawed at it with a knife until his face
was, well, faceless.
This means of infection by way of info hazard
was most notably observed with researcher
Hayward, when he was reading revision 2 of
SCP-1903.
By the time he finished, he saw SCP-1903 staring
at him from across the cell through the observatory
window.
She was trying to warn him not to read it.
She didn't say anything, but she shushed him.
He pressed the button for a photograph and
tried to talk to her through the intercom,
but when he did, she just sat back down on
her cot.
He assumed that she realized he was reading
her file and then tried to warn him not to
tell anyone.
While the story of SCP-1903 was going around
infecting people and causing them intense
physical and psychological pain, SCP-1903
herself was trying to save them from it.
This is the tragic through-line of the story.
Jackie Barter spent her whole life making
other people feel better.
In most cases, this meant sacrificing her
time and energy to do so.
And her payment for these services wasn’t
fair.
What did she get?
She was sentenced to life under strict supervision.
A life in pain.
A life in a body that isn’t her own.
But this is often overlooked.
The most documented and studied pain wasn’t
of SCP-1903’s but rather the personnel who
were affected by her story.
In fact, there are few documented records
of how SCP-1903 itself feels.
However, we have interviews with researcher
Hayward explaining how he felt after being
affected.
And maybe, with time, as Hayward moves further
and further away from his time as a normal
human being, we will begin to disregard his
pain too.
In science, empathy often finds a way to elude
us.
With each new study, we move closer to an
objective understanding, but at the cost of
traveling further and further from its emotional
makeup.
Regarding Hayward, he initially felt fine
after the affliction.
But in a couple of hours, the affected areas
started to feel irritated.
Nothing that couldn’t be managed though.
He didn’t think much of it until the second
day.
By then, it felt like he had spent the day
on the beach staring up at the hot sun.
But he remembers not having been in the sun
at all that day.
Even under a layer of clouds and low temperatures,
the skin on his face felt to have been roasting
as if in the oven.
His face was slowly peeling off.
If he tugged at the corner, he swore it would
have ripped off like a Band-Aid.
The pain and discomfort didn’t end there.
The testing for mercury wasn't much fun either
for him, however, he was quite reluctant to
go into details about how the procedure was
done, similar to how your dad would respond
if you asked him about his colonoscopy.
Even now, Hayward’s face is still tender.
A gentle kiss on the cheek would feel like
a pinch.
But the worst pain wasn’t physical.
It was the mental games it played with his
head.
He experienced hallucinations.
He started seeing them around the time he
noticed that the mask finished growing.
They blended with reality and it took him
time to start recognizing their onset.
He could tell he was hallucinating if he focused
on people's clothing, because in his hallucinations
their outfits would change until everyone
was wearing a white tux or a white evening
gown.
The dresses would be classy yet revealing.
Similar to how the women would dress at Donnar’s
establishment.
In fact, most everything in the hallucinations
could be called back to Donnar’s.
The people in the hallucinations would be
wearing masks of different animal types, just
like Jackie and her coworkers.
Hayward said it looked like a masquerade where
he was the center of attention.
Everyone would turn their heads to face him,
even if their necks should've snapped.
They’d turn a full 180.
And they’d just glare.
These hallucinations would last close to thirty
seconds.
And during that half minute, one thing stood
out specifically.
There would be a man leaning against the wall,
not wearing a mask.
He was the only one who wasn’t in stylish
evening wear, so he kind of sticks out.
He can’t be made out clearly, but by studying
the description, The Foundation believes it
to be a vision of Donnar.
Could Donnar be a more important piece to
this story than we give him credit?
The person trying hardest to silence the story
must have the most skin in the game of secrets,
right?
Either way, we can all learn a lesson from
Donnar and keep quiet from time to time.
I will say it again.
Sometimes when someone spills the tea… we
all get burned.
Now go check out “SCP-3887 - Monster Under
the Bed” and “The Horror of Body Stealing
Rain - SCP-3300” for more haunting anomalies
that’ll stay with you forever…